on this week's show how to secure your
first HMO deal in the news a new portal
to an property potential to rule out in
the UK and we're gonna be answering all
your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I almost lead some alistair cunningham
and welcome to this week's property
investors podcast i'm actually looking
forward to this show but if you're gonna
do talking about HMOs which particularly
covered certainly in detail on the on
the pond now a common question I get a
lot is people have just got into
property and they really want to get
into HMO straight away but they don't
really know how they can because those
obviously those restrictions or bulldogs
three minutes into the podcast he's
already started right okay three minutes
that was a free minutes 10 seconds okay
right so hate chemours
it's gonna be good before we get into
that what we've been able to this way
Romney or what I know they're going is I
wanna cut evening car shopping earlier
basically you solve you yeah so I we
look both looking for a new car both
looking at the same time at the same
shop for a new car yeah what you going
for you know I'm so unbelievably
undecided between two yeah which to
which - I know but this is for the
benefit of the viewers yeah because they
all care so badly so the two that I'm
undecided between yet is the Range Rover
Sport very nice it is very nice
interestingly I had one my wife's got
Range Rover Evoque and that broke the
Range Rover Walker broke no a Range
Rover broke it did hit a new Range Rover
it was like three one's old reliable
aren't they no and anyway we took it
back and the courtesy car they gave my
wife was are a brand new Range Rover
Sport mmm it was beautiful it is
beautiful lovely car and I even took a
video and sent it to you a very nice car
very nice all three of us and boil
through this I mean Samuel and myself
and I stare all buying new cars at the
exact same time
yes she's quite interesting Samuel was
just like an arranger over he doesn't
really he's not into cars is he really
just he just wants something that's away
you can get the sport is not no Range
Rover but the shape of the sports bettor
because of this you know it's 20 grand
manan Range Rover Range Rover so he's
not but where was we've been talking
about it a lot haven't we yes because
we're into cars a little bit more yes
Range Rover Sport for the first time
what's your sport is my sensible option
yeah that's just being you've already
got a big sensible option in your family
what the GLA yeah the jeely the Marek
yeah I know but I don't really drive
that it's kind of Anna's car yeah no but
two big cars and the same family so if
you go out with the kids and that you'd
go out in Anna's car yeah I think you
get something fun well that's fast
that's my over that's my other option I
think we should we're both going because
I haven't seen a Porsche the Porsche
Porsche is Porsche Porsche no it's not
well Nick is it Porter Porter I on the
end there's a tunnel a on the end ok
Google how do you pronounce Porsche
let's see what says if we've got enough
4G in this God forsaken place can't me
given at the moment oh come on do trucks
you know what I see real understanding
it because ok Google how do you
pronounce Porsche
tricera ok Google how to pronounce
Porsche Porsche that's how you pronounce
it I don't believe that my enemy is on
Google mind you you're Scottish you
pronounce something which one don't say
it
panorama panorama no Cayman No
911 yes I know four states
it's got four seats are in between
practice being practical but not being
practical
yeah if you're having a 911 I'm not
having a came in
you haven't came no no we discussed this
yesterday you're having a caiman and
that's happening you I came no I was a
911 but they're more money yeah I'm not
sure my um torn
I think the Keemun is a brilliant car I
rode tested one last week last see I
actually want the Cayman yeah but I
can't help but think two seats the
problem is I did look in a 911 and I sat
on 9/11 and the seats in the back are
pointless see but I've got no no
three-year-old or four-year-old there's
no leg room at all that bet their three
informant yeah but they wouldn't even
get their small legs down there's no
space in the back you couldn't the I
don't even know whether they are there
are absolutely pointless bit of baby
everyone than the yet cannot even put
your leg then cuz if you if you you're
quite tall so sorry your seats gonna be
right back you will not get anyone sat
there so what am I gonna have to go for
what's the what's the what's the saloon
the sporty slit panorama Pat penitent we
know our stuff on here because pronounce
it it's the port perimortem panorama I
might go for that then and then you can
have the came and then Panamera saucepan
and mirar I'm not a big fan I like it
but I thought one thing is nice is like
the 911 or the Cayman will get the came
in there and I'll get the panorama you
like I'll get Cayman and you'll rock hop
in the 911 you're getting your [ __ ] are
forest okay okay yeah I'm happy to get
the car first almighty the Range Rover
Sport either no I'm told that's what we
be able to do this week anyway just
arguing about cars what color you gonna
go for ah see Range Rover on no black
black black 400% the one Lisa had four
quarts car was like a graphite to agree
very
I'd want to go what if we're going for
the Porsche I'd want to go for a
brighter color so red also you do two
Reds they do the standard red which is
included in the car and it's more like
it's like a very bright red it's very
it's a bit more Orange II might
therefore that no I would go for the the
carmine red it's an extra twelve hundred
pounds but it is a beautiful red it's
like a proper sports car red okay I
think it's much nicer and it goes really
nice with the black wheels okay maybe
that mm maybe
well sorry awesome colors yeah that's
true that's true you should go for like
a blue Scotland
I don't follow football but you have to
fight football for Scotland ooh you
don't for Scotland because I believe
they're quite rubbish at football they
are why would a follow us Robert shoot
both him that's a very good question
because you've meant to be loyal there's
Nick for Aston belong yeah so they ask
him him there anyway for anyone
listening to this sorry this is not a
culture this is a property show so let's
move towards enough about cars there's
gonna get negative comments we get a car
shows a property show moo-moo-moo-moo
were you wasting my time man well you're
wasting your own time listening to us no
one forced you to okay
property should I say that on our own
show you're wasting your time listening
to us wasting your time guys wasting
yeah why not why not
anyway properties HMOs okay so very
quickly HMO what is a hate remote house
much Multiple Occupation and it's where
you have a house and you have lots of
people living there lots people living
there and the oldest event rooms
basically yeah you can I have on sweets
gnawing on sweets you can have for three
people up to 20 people 50 people it
doesn't matter yeah there's no size and
restrictions but obviously you've got
regulations you've got restrictions
you've got rules you've got laws you've
got planning permission so if you were
getting started now
yeah what room so let's let's describe
what we need probably if you were
getting started now from scratch never
done I hate summer before in your life
or a multi layer in your life what are
you gonna start with who's your target
market where you gonna look and firstly
you need to identify your goldmine your
gold may impact your area yeah and then
so how do we do that how do you find our
area firstly you need to determine what
sort of type of telling you want do you
want working professionals doing
students if you want students go to
somewhere where there's a large student
population University cities that don't
have lots of their own accommodation or
just just anyway that's got large
college campuses students students will
prevail that's the first place okay
what's the pros and cons pros well
students are the generally a bit more
consistent because they know they're
going to be in that area for a period of
time so you can get students booking and
sitting in that accommodation for a long
period of time and they generally paying
in blocks because they're there four
times at the time you don't know we get
12 month control you get it's normal I
think it's 10 or 11 months obviously
they go home for some some period of
time that does have its benefits that
the fact they leave the property and
I'll talk about a minute but the main
goods on salt a little refund yeah but
it's time to get in there and meet you
the properties describe one of the big
amount of students well sometimes that
can sometimes be the difference between
our property having a good R or Y or not
yesterday certainly makes up for the
missing month yeah that's kind of the
missing actually you think where it's
probably two months because if you see
most like that probably we were
discussing yesterday we had some 35
Panama well we arms 12 what's that well
10 1600 ish yes Ivy isn't it being made
that the profile of let's just take a
full bed hit Jamal
typically the profit and that would be
anywhere from five to so I'm gonna be
eight hundred-pound sometimes a little
bit more the other thing with students
is they pay quite a lot don't know they
generally pay a little bit more than
than the going rate no I that's what I
found anyway and because more student
holes are 120 to 140 a week doesn't
matter where they're on the country
now yes the country and the gems of good
standard so as long as you probably are
of good standard then you can achieve
decent money yeah Meg student that is
throw is horrible what I found with them
shouldn't list whenever I'm at viewing
properties and you weren't a student
property it's generally filthy yeah
it's generally a little bit tired run
down the the don't wanna treat it with
respect
we went into that student like the floor
they'd never been hoovered clearly the
whole time they've been there Lord do
you know the kitchen vinyl it was like
bin and you know every one of these old
grotty pops we're like you're walking
and you're sticking to the floor that's
what they had their posters up on the
walls they stuck them up with chewing
gum it's not like it's not like it's an
urgent rush to put your poster on the
wall it's not like I need it now it's
like you go and buy some blue tack yeah
or you just don't stick posters on the
wall like it's like a 12 year old sure I
also in this in this one property the
Vorbis it means the smell of weed in
this house was ridiculous I think we all
got high just walking in it but that's
one of the advantages that's a good
vantage but the in the rooms they've
also been smoking in their bedrooms and
one of the bedrooms when the guy
finished his cigarette or a single we
looked out on the wall his plug he's
just stubborn out on the water and all
the all the all around the walls what's
it called you know it's like the alcove
market raves and not yeah its grounds
was all like yellow yeah because it's
because of the smoke and I don't think
they've ever done the washing up in
their life like dirty dishes everywhere
you would not want to eat in that
kitchen you would not want to cook in
that kitchen
it just grim and you know they didn't
want to go into the bathroom having said
that you haven't got to live there this
so no but you've got our
responsibilities come on man like but if
I want my tenants living in a good nice
property yeah I wouldn't want any much I
wouldn't put any prop in tents and that
probably what you could do those you
could let them live in it and ruin it
over the year they're mainly ruining it
by just being disgusting it's not
tidying up himself give her a good
industrial clean freshen it up
their mum out and then just let your new
Terence come in but you're gonna have to
bait I think you're basically gonna have
to refurb it every single yeah yeah not
not an expensive reverb but you probably
have to better ground that's the case
everywhere across the country I think
it's more likely to be happening in
every student however I mean to be in
all fairness I've never rented my
property students so I can't speak from
I've always gotten professional ropes
but but everyone have ever been have
been lots obviously move Management
Agency and stuff and I've seen a lot of
my friends are doing it every time I've
ever been Iman they've always been
horrible yeah you know TV but the other
advantage of it being horrible though is
they've got really low standards yeah
like if you've got one of the problems
with professional housemates is when one
of them's dirty they all moan about it
at least you this they're all disgusting
together just not have aid they've got I
like I just can't I go in the house I'm
like how can they live in this house I
must have met a lot the house I go into
to view I'm like this is grim it is
great that is a good word for it
how can they how can they live how can
they cook in this kitchen even like some
of the showers that you look at they're
just the shower they've broken the show
and they just stuck it back up with
gaffer tape yeah literally to know that
during the bit attaches to the wall
nothing it was just from the taps Gaffa
tape to the wall it's just like it's
unbelievable
there is law I have got friends are
students and I've been to their houses
and they're actually quite nice because
they if you've got frightened I bet your
friends a shooter shouldn't 19 well no
then the young but I wouldn't say their
friends are just people I know through
all the people who ever but there are I
think there are bad I think they're just
a bad quality of tell no one and there
are early twenties but not all students
I go test pigs
saying that which is finding that the
way that they do learn to live live yeah
but I certainly know at least OB
students listen to this at Brooklyn and
colony oh you're talking about maybe we
don't but we just took you in our
experience and which is the Fiona it's a
grim pit yeah to be honest we've been in
a lot of HMOs are frequented by students
and they're all horrible and disgusting
and it's living it and then you just go
in once a year it's bender grams from
changing all the bed linen and touching
it up give it a good industrial clean
yeah it depends I'm not I'm not
comfortable my property's been in that
condition
I don't know so anyways that students
professionals but they're better they're
a little bit better but again it depends
on the type of healing you're after that
like I know people that have got tenon I
like to go high-end yeah same as but I
do know people that I've got tenants
that are like professionals the doctors
they're walking in a professional job
and they live like pigs really yeah and
they don't they they're always late I
honestly I know people so hate Remos is
a tough market you've got to do your
homework do your research you cannot do
not just don't do not get blinded by the
the the feeling that the cash flow is
gonna be awesome the Castro is awesome
it is awesome but you gotta get it right
don't think it's easy because it's not
by far the simplest strategy is just
single by it'll AIDS
you won't make as much money but the
more money you make the more hassle
you're going to have in a more risk
you're going to have okay so the
question was that if you were starting
from students professionals what you're
gonna go for I would always go for
professional okay so go for
professionals so where are we gonna look
then a big city that is doing well
financially there's got lots of jobs of
that is on the OP that is somewhere
where people want to live people have
jobs people want to work but there's
businesses and Industry common to that
area and it's not on a downward spiral
but at the same time
you want some we're we're into four
levels why the house to make his stack
yeah
now in some moves book by the ran high
yeah he wrote that a few years ago now
and in that book he states 25,000 pound
per letter ballroom yep
so if you bought if you were doing a for
bet HMO you'd be looking at a hundred
thousand half of the house does that
still stand in areas yeah absolutely
I think morning like he was aiming sort
more at the Midlands when he wrote that
book of my understanding but obviously
the Midlands has gone up in price I
think it's more like 30,000 35,000 per
room certainly up north you can achieve
a property definitely for less than
hundred thousand for forward you could
probably a five bit or even a 6 bed 400
K so you want to find a city that's not
too saturated it's a lot of a lot of the
a lot of the cities of either an article
for what's happened but obviously but
article for coming in you've got a
little bit of saturation happening in
certain places you find this though do
you find that the saturation is for the
low end properties yep 100% she go for
Austin Lee if you go for a hot if you
got on sweets and let me tell you
something yeah sorry I don't want to
interrupt you I'm nice and play you just
in front the whole time but let me total
Monroe kind of did just interrupt me I
know and then you said you didn't want
to didn't want to not do it but you
didn't stop let me finish she was
carried on but carry on and it yeah okay
right okay so and about four or five
months ago we sourced a property for our
overseas investor as Chinese investor
she been here probably two or three
times but she doesn't actually come to
the UK to get any properties she's got
quite a few properties in the UK
probably I think seven or eight and she
asked us to find her property handle the
management doing everything she does not
want to be involved she also has to do
is pay the bills she's very good at that
literally we sent her an invoice it's
paid within an hour very very good the
property went on the market last Monday
with by Wednesday sheets filled all four
rooms and they're all moving in two days
in two days
described also the property was quite a
rundown property we bought it
it's a buy refocused refinance property
so we've done the property she paid for
it cash initially and then she
refinanced it so she's pulled a lot of
not all of it but a lot of our money out
we the property was done to are very
high-end
now it's not all ensuite but one of the
bedrooms is ensuite and then there's a
downstairs toilet which you've managed
to get a shower cubicle into and then
you've got the main bathroom upstairs so
there's basically three very bed sorry
about three bathrooms two four rooms so
one one rooms not three rooms have not
got on Suites but they've got two
bathrooms to share big kitchen really
done to a really good standard and she's
achieving like 350 per room she's got
two year contract for the tenants Wow
because we put her in touch with the
right agents it's a nice day she's got
two-year ast but it's one like a
corporate late type agreement to the age
to the company so they're gonna put
their staff in there so um she's got
two-year contract paying fourteen
hundred pounds a month repair room
perfect the property me I don't know the
exact figures cuz not gotten to hand but
I believe she's running late for about
seven or eight thousand ponen in the
deal after all the course and all sort
stuff and the refinance and so the key
is doing it to a high end I think due to
heart failure bathroom when plenty of
bathrooms cuz look think about it guys
if you've got hate you more would you
want to share a bathroom with somebody
else I will not wear never share a
bathroom as anybody any wife thank you
not a normal wife but I wouldn't share
about Joe someone that you knew yes we
said you would share of anybody it
wasn't true do you know you know maybe
we share woman yes yeah oh I lived in I
hate chat more I wouldn't want to [ __ ]
with another tenant but even my hate
German Wolverhampton and I went there
cuz obviously one of our one of our
staff works air lives there and I went
to pick him up and I just said I'm just
gonna pop in and use the toilet and I
went in I meant I'm alright thanks I'd
rather wait myself even the toilet you
can just stand from afar and it was I
went in and it was like I spent money
dicker in this place and you autry know
that this actually just a thanks I'll
run P behind the bush in the park it was
that bad it's it's grim made for total
Stadium
very not football season so I don't
understand or get football to be honest
a lot of people kick in a bag of air
around it's not my thing
I got a concert then don't go to
concerts what do you do know a lot have
you ever been right talking about grim
toilets have you ever been to a festival
yes they're grim
they I went to Leeds Festival or maybe
18 months ago yeah and I just couldn't
believe how disgusting it was I
literally I was just uncomfortable the
whole time I'm a little bit of a high
genic clean freak though and I was like
oh my the smell it was just remembering
Uganda remember the Leeds fest was worse
the village communal village although
that was worse
yeah you can't it was worse Leeds
Festivals clothes seriously great may
you go in that's what it is but you can
see everything in there it's terrible
anyway my point was gonna be do you go
to the toilet we went to the festival
I would of can't remember all that
experience but I would of but you
wouldn't go in your own hay to write
your hater moments I was I was I was
wearing a suit and I went in and it was
just it was rubbish everywhere and it
was just like it wasn't Pleasant and I
was actually a little bit disappointed
and because it's my HMO I spent a lot of
money in that property yeah and they're
just not looking after the place like
the kitchens got pots and pans
everywhere there's bag of rubbish on the
floor it's just they're always I find it
really disheartened and spend all that
money in that property and I actually
said to my HMO manager I'm never going
back to that property and I want him to
take full control and I want him to all
no one's really like is all don't worry
well he knows never coming back no no
you're my tenants don't need to know
that my hitchmo manager I cuz I cuz I
was officer I'll pick the member of
staff up from there
interestingly he's got he has got an
ensuite so it's not not not down to him
but um I said to me two more - I'm not
gonna back though I said so if anything
he's doing you need to sort out and he
manages property anyway but I do pop
head no and again and she did the little
repair if I need to do I don't wanna be
involved you want to say it it's too too
disheartening they're annoying it's just
really annoying or my money is just so
make me a professional that were then
gonna go to a city center there's a
good-looking city center something that
people want to live yesBut easy access
to everything so town center is it's no
use having a hitch em all in the middle
and always check on places like spare
room you can sort of check the demand
for the area and speak to the local HMO
manager stuff so you pick your area well
how many rooms did you go for I the
closest ones I've got a theory on this
yeah let me explain my theory on how
many rooms you should go for yeah so
this is my theory on how many rooms I
think you should I mean if you go for a
massive one great but will you start
enough I'd say go small yeah because
you're getting used to how it works you
know when it's less of a risk yeah I
would say either go for yeah we'll go
six yeah I don't like five right the
reason I like five is five is where all
the licensing and everything starts so
you if you get it you might as well do
four over five but if you're gonna
bother with five you might have to say
there's a lot sakes here yeah cuz I
think four or six I would say for your
first one probably go for yeah four is
the easiest if you if you're gonna do
your first one and because it's probably
the yes it's the easiest in the sense or
if you don't have to have licensing yeah
but you do still have to have like
immunity standards with a council so you
still have to be a responsible landlord
we'd always recommend doing fire doors
fire safety all sort of stuff yeah speak
to your local council don't just because
you're licensed does not mean you've got
you've not got landlord responsibilities
yeah so you still have to be a good
landlord the license is essentially a
bit of paper that says they've been out
and they've they've confirmed you're a
good landlord but you do need to do that
but I agree with you and the additional
costs of Licensing is not worth that
extra bedroom income I would go six or
seven would you want so would you say
for bed and maybe go for like
the bathrooms yeah I just changed how I
feel about this now so I was very happy
exchanged out I think the market was
fine with having four bedrooms share my
bathroom I think now it's all on sweets
if you want to really maximize your
income this will tell you why that it's
Marcus change because there's more
people doing it yeah and then the
competition has improved yeah and
therefore if you do if you still do the
old way do you know what I think but the
competition hits you're more it sucks
it's rubbish because most people most
hate your mores are rubbish yeah they're
rubbish they're very poorly run like
even little things that I've been in I
don't hate you more last week and I'm
walking around and to me this is just a
really annoying petty little thing but
I'm walking around upstairs and all you
can hear is - for the floorboards
creaking and everyone speak walking
about because they put like the cheapest
complet down with no underlay and it's
just ridiculous they've just gone
they've won cheap and they say why did
you do that why don't you spend the NATO
cup on a pumpkin so underlay probably
because they know the people in a treat
like crap if it and I think if you give
somebody a nicer place in the first
place they'll look after a better I
really do like em if you give them if
you just do it nice on their gonna I
think that's true to a point but even it
doesn't cost much more money to do it
nicer so carpet in a whole house let's
just take a typical sort of four bedroom
hm or with communal it's gonna cost you
about a thousand at twelve hundred it's
not going to cost your Niall it's not
going to cost you it's gonna cost you a
couple under pound to get under leap it
down I don't know why people don't go
underlay then it's ridiculous
mmm my gray but it's just stupid I don't
understand why they don't do that and
then another thing I would think the
mark is men dictating on sweets because
every HTML manager I speak to they all
see what is your nature more when I meet
we see them it's for bed two bathrooms
and they it's fine it will get X amount
for a month if you make it ensuite it
will no get
and it will win out super quick so I
think once you picture area everyone
walks on switch there's not many
available something available so you're
standing out from the competition well
I'm not actually I'm not gonna sit up so
I'll give away a bit for information
there's no pulling this shows
oh yeah it's yeah so if you go on sweets
and all properties you can then make you
can take a conventional property convert
the bathroom into a bedroom and then
have on to eternal bedrooms so you get
more space our house and blessing is
interesting mm-hmm that's not about
anywhere that would have really worked
the property we looked at the other day
yeah the bathroom was a fungus a huge
one it was ridiculous it was like a
double bedroom in cost yeah and you
could have an ensuite on so he wants to
be honest he knocks his bathroom mm-hmm
do you think you could do it for that
bathroom for example you could have
split that into three bathrooms
so rather than on interest an idea have
three separations but obviously it very
easily that will even cost that much
you're not gonna have toilets and
bedrooms so you would still need toilet
really wcq before that bathroom for
example was massive right you cause yeah
what you could do you could almost a
bang-bang
Jannetty corridor feel ya like children
not go look at this change I guess we'll
all mostly you know like we've got that
was an interesting property that one
yeah I think that'll be bad because
that'd be a lot cheaper just putting
your shower use down the side and all
the doors in and the thing is all the
waterworks are there the pipes are you
got the running of piping
hmm large bathroom like this sure this
stuff you can do to my area but feel
very students either yeah it's not I
still cherish out I roll out my own
shower yeah you know but then obviously
I think like to see the markets are
dictating that and and the the good
thing about all this new licensing laws
is getting rid of a lot of the rule 10
in the rural landlords they're all given
up in the sale or not because they can't
afford to do what they've got to do yeah
because they've just been running it for
the money which is fine but you wanna
roll through Samuels five steps to for
the five step rules for for finding HMO
just yeah basic rule one
plus the city center generally 1050
minutes but not by car walking or public
transport leo level room yeah minimum
for lateral rooms
rule 3 25 k palatable room that's still
that's still valid up north but mean in
the Midlands I would say 30 to 35
depends on the area look at your ROI
yeah all right I've got investors that
would pay they they would they would pay
fifty thousand pound per level room it
doesn't matter it just depends on all
right rule for good condition good
condition and real fine wide good
condition because you don't want to be
spending loads of money on it and you
want to start with a good base if the
walls are falling down you're gonna let
clever and do like a buy refurbish
refinance yes yes that and rule five
- manager makes you got a good agent
nearby property manager nearby brim it's
now time for this
[Music]
okay so this I think is pretty exciting
yes all right so a a property potential
portal yeah claims which claims to be
highly successful across the Southeast
of England so it's already in you can
have a look at this jet out now it's now
going to launch across the rest of the
UK so since the end of 27th its 2017 the
portal it's called upshoot okay has
listed property as listed properties
currently on sale in the southeast along
with the usual details the portals
algorithms reveal what they believe the
development potential of each property
is illustrating what could be achieved
on each in terms of alteration and
extension users can then get ups you to
provide free 3d interactive models of
each property costings and an indication
of the potential uplift in value once
the work has been completed currently
has 25,000 visits per month assessing
the development potential of 50,000 plus
properties prompting the committee
behinds is it to expand it from its
current patch of its inland company in
London Surrey Sussex and Kent so that's
basically all it does they're looking at
bring it across the UK I just thought
for me very interesting for Barry
probably fans yeah that would be like
Goldust yeah so I would pay that I said
I would if that was like a monthly
subscription I would pay like a lot for
that yeah if I'd always want them to
charge for it so that stopped anyone
else even though I didn't use it yeah I
think they should sell that for like I
would yeah I would happily pay 100 per a
month for that depends that accurately
is yeah I mean have to say I mean I
don't
well it's very very interesting I wonder
what it takes into account when if it
takes into account planning permission
and said that they are the the fabric M
the factor in all things that costs and
things out so yeah they'll have all that
like how amazing is that
it must take a lot to be honest yeah
what are the properties this is a
mission to go low information yeah so
obviously that's all I mean I'm assuming
it's gonna be similar to mean that Mouse
price where it's it's a guide it's no I
find I think that would be more accurate
because most price doesn't give you
information on like refurb costs and
things that who I mean is is that the
stuff mass price does give you yeah
and I imagine that will be similar it's
gonna be a guide but Wow
it's gonna be very very interesting it
it's great so there you go something to
look out for I just came across that
today and I was like wow that's sounds
amazing I'm gonna have a look at it yep
brilliant right it's now time to answer
all your property related questions
[Music]
so what questions you got for words this
week okay guy Luke
Alaric Keith Luke Elric Keith hello Luke
I challenge summer leads to invest my
money and make it into a success as I
know he likes a challenge and it would
be great great help to me well it's not
really a challenge isn't it why would he
do private time to up when he's got it's
all money well there skate yourself
along and crash caused me and invest
your money what's that what's that was I
don't understand I wasn't actually
question I don't know not question buddy
okay next one will be you're the one
that read it you have to read it okay
even into a question bit where didn't
okay so Michael Santos how do you choose
an area for sourcing and how do you know
it's a goldmine area good question well
who's the still sore out the two of us
me okay so choose an area first need to
make sure was demand you need to make
sure those properties you need to make
sure they're in specialist properties of
course yeah that's tasks that there you
go that is the golden tip so when you
don't don't go invest in the sea for
example not a great place to invite if
there's no properties no an area that's
tip them a want to find an area that has
properties no properties no good right
that's anymore it's amazing any more
gold dust well look you could go to
Scotland and nobody's lovely place to
invest but you're not gonna rain - how
are you cuz there's no demand you know
anyway and you should know properties
yeah make sure there's properties that
you can buy for your budget
go on so you weren't affordable
properties that you can convert into
whatever you want to use them for you
want demand you want an hour vibrant
area so please what people wants to live
and places where there's things to do
places where there's buzzing nightlife
places where people are somewhere where
people don't want to live
make sure there's properties there and
make sure those properties that people
want if it's an abandoned
where nobody wants to live don't don't
do it doesn't matter how cheap it is
don't go there so with those two gold
dust tips from the deal sourcing man
himself I think that kind of concludes
that question for then make sure his
properties may still help you people
want to live it all right next question
thank you for that question Michael I
hope we covered that in detail do you
want to add anything else or do you feel
that those two those two tips cover it
yeah you need to have roads roads yeah
make sure this row wise people will be
able to get the B properties there and I
want to live in those properties but if
they come on drive there what are they
gonna do okay nice one I'm glad to you
answer that question
I've never handed it over to you did
such a great job okay Daniel Roberts as
asks this hey Daniel how you doing but I
how do you calculate the void periods to
minimize risk we work off approximately
attempts M so when you work it out
assume you're really gonna get it
occupied 9% of the time yeah so just
like M turn off the rent all right next
thank you that question Daniel hope that
answered your question again it's just a
rule of thumb but when you're doing sort
of like this you can only you can only
enroll of thumb unless you've got what
you want if you were no more no more but
we'd say as a minimum temperature
Brandon Fox hey Brandon do you you need
to know the mortgage payments of the
property you're looking at to work out
the ROI yes otherwise you wouldn't know
a real question that's a real question
yes Brandon you do absolutely and in the
next question but is if so yes you do
what's the method of working out the
mortgage payments on a property well
without going to a mortgage broker
you're not going to get a totally
accurate figure but again never a nice
rule of thumb is what I'm letting you
answer this okay three percent yeah okay
so basically if you've burned the house
one hundred thousand pounds you get a
twenty five percent deposit so you need
a percent mortgage the rule of thumb is
it's going to be seventy five thousand
pounds divide that by three percent or
times up by three percent divided by
twelve
that'll give you your monthly payments
of are by twelve oh yeah moose bombers
yeah and that will just that be let's
actually do that right now yeah just
because can I have my phone because I
can do it quickly I'm doing it right
okay so I don't know where the
calculator is on my phone right so they
should say you've got a hundred thousand
pound house so you know you're gonna
have to put a twenty five percent
deposit what good it's gonna be
seventy-five thousand pounds so I know
you can't see this times by naught point
naught 3 as a three percent
Noorie that's a ballpark figure and
maybe Gimli it's a little bit alike I've
got I just got back like mortgage it was
two point two six or whatever this is
interest only just rule of thumb yeah
yep
two point two thousand two hundred and
fifty for their annual mortgage payments
debate by twelve and the mortgage on a
seventy five thousand pounds the
payments on a thousand per mortgage even
be one hundred neat seven perfectly a
month rule of thumb it's not a hundred
inaccurate speak the mortgage broker and
get find out the exact interest rate
you'll be peeing but approximately 310
is a very good figure to walk off so
actually although we took the mick I was
actually a really good question Brandon
can take it cuz he's in the Academy he
got have a question I was looking for
questions but there's a really long run
in your base the guy's just trying to
get us to promote his business that's
not going to happen you're welcome to
contact our ad revenue team and they
will charge you accordingly but having
that driven you to know just send us
some money and we'll do it for you Allan
hassle this last one now last one this
is the last one with lease option
agreement is it better to do them in
your own name or a limited company it's
a good question is a good question
limited company yeah I would always do a
limited company to protect yourself a
limited company last question last one
this guy I'm the reason I'm getting this
one is because he comments a lot and he
does Shira stuff Richard or blaster his
poor men was he loves the shelves in the
background what there's no there's no
shelves ah that'll be mean Facebook live
earlier of course why would we think he
was talking about now when this is being
not-not-not sent out live we're both
just like what
well anyway they were a lovely shelf
switcher I'm glad you appreciate the the
finery of this building we're in amazing
guys thanks for tuning in don't forget
to tune in next week we're back at the
same day same time and we'll see you
there
[Applause]